i knew that at some point he had to
admit
that he was going to use it but i said
why not now
and he said not it's not ready yet this
isn't the time yet
so i think what he is preparing for
is something really big on election
night
i'm dave rubin and this is the reuben
report quick reminder everybody to
subscribe to our youtube
channel so you actually get notified of
our new videos
and joining me today is a former new
york state prosecutor and judge
host of justice with judge jeanine on
fox news and author
of the new book don't lie to me and stop
trying to steal our freedom
judge jeanine pirro welcome to the
reuben report
well it's a pleasure to be with you and
on the other end actually and i really
appreciate you plugging my book
right off the bat in fact i have it
right here behind me
right under don't burn this book so as
you can see you know it's a 50 50 here
people will decide
your book or my book probably your
juicier
no no no no no this is going to be all
about your book and i have to tell
people a couple
insider things before we fully start
here because although we have not met in
real life yet because of this coded
ridiculousness
i i've been doing your show a bunch and
i feel like we have this
this kinship even though we haven't
actually broken bread yet or anything
and one of the things that strikes me
about you is i do a lot of the fox shows
and on no other show does the host call
the guest
before but you call me when i'm on
usually on saturdays when you're live
you call me in the afternoon you ask how
i'm doing and then you always say
and what's on your mind what are you
thinking about what's going on and
that strikes me as just very different
than how all
of cable news is done that you're just
really interested
in talking about what people really care
about
is that fair to say judge jeanine how
was that for a first question
well first of all it was it was very
informative
because i have no idea how the other
people do their shows on fox
but what i can tell you is it maybe it's
my background that speaks to
who i am i am a little different from
those people on fox i mean i've been a
prosecutor a judge and a d.a
for 32 years i ran for office five times
i mean i have a different background and
a different skill set
and to this day i'll say i need a good
witness for this one
and you know it's not a witness it's a
guest obviously
uh but i really think it's important
that people come on a show
and talk about what's important to them
and as long as we have an intersection
where it's important up to me and i
believe then to the public
that that's your passion you know that's
what you're interested in
then you literally jump off the screen
because
to me passion is everything and i've
long believed
i tried jury i tried jury trials i was a
litigator
for many years and it's what moves me
it's what moves people
so i didn't know any of that or that
other people didn't do that but i always
like to get a sense of what you want to
talk about
and where your head is i don't rely on
other people to screen my guests
that's not what i do yeah do you like
doing the tv stuff
more than being a prosecutor or being a
judge or do you just think it's
exercising like a different skill set
or something like that well you gave me
a great out right there
exercising a different skill set but the
truth is
the best job in the world was being a
prosecutor dave i mean without
a doubt and i'll tell you why i don't
mean a prosecutor in this sense that you
know you're out there
and you know locking people up no being
a prosecutor to me
was about making victims whole again at
least to the extent that you can
it might even be just the victims
families but you know
when i first started prosecuting crimes
i became an assistant d.a in 1975
which you know my kids will tell you
that's when they wrote the laws on stone
tablets and stopped counting my age i
see your eyes
um and it was like the the victims were
nothing more than
a an element of the case the people of
the state of new york against john smith
all right but to me the victim was the
reason we were there
the victim was a person who never chose
to be a victim
who never chose to be the system in the
first place
and so my energies were trying to make
that victim whole again whether the
victim was a five-year-old who had been
raped
and didn't know the language you know
just said peachy pie my honey bun
and teaching them with anatomically
correct dolls how they could communicate
with a jury
or a senior citizen who ended up losing
you know her house because she was a
victim of economic crimes
so that to me was my passion and i did
it for many decades
um i went to the bench because to be a
judge
you know it's supposed to be the citadel
of the practice of law
hogwash it's not i felt like a referee
i felt that when i was a judge sitting
on the bench
you know i would sustain an objection
overrule an objection they'd come up to
me and they'd argue
and i wanted to be in the fight you know
it's not really my personality so
i had a 10-year term and after three
years i
i said i've had enough of this i ran for
judge i was the first woman judge in the
history
a county judge in the history of the
county and
i said i can't take this anymore this is
too slow for me
and i remember that i had uh i spoke to
the chief administrative judge and i
said you know judge
if you while i'm taking a plea
with one defendant if you could bring
have the court officers bring another
defendant out of the bullpen
his lawyer can talk to him and then as
soon as this plea is over
he's ready to plea or whatever the
motion could be and i thought i was so
sharp
right and i'd move things along i said i
could handle twice the cases
and his response was are you trying to
make the men look bad janine
and no i i didn't take it personally but
i thought to myself
whether this is sexist or not doesn't
matter
this is not the speed that i work at so
i stepped off the bench
and i ran for district attorney because
i was a fighter i started the first
domestic violence unit in the country
you know uh first hate crimes unit in
the history of my county sex
crimes unit uh and and worked with you
know
card john cardinal o'connor and trying
to make sure
that everyone was covered under hate
crimes it wasn't just
you know uh gender and ethnicity
and color but sexual orientation as well
and as president
of the da's association john cardinal
o'connor who was beloved in new york
went in and supported that and it became
part of new york law
so where i saw problems
i was able to move the legislature
if i had enough support believe me i
don't think singularly i could
but i could do something to try to make
a difference
where i saw a victimization i would go
out there and publicly say
with the advent of the internet your
kids cannot use the
the the pc as a babysitter
and i started the first internet
pedophile sting operation in the nation
and we arrested doctors lawyers priests
coaches school superintendents ceos
you name it and it was very satisfying
for me but i
gave that job update because i felt
that i had done it enough and it was
kind of like my own self-imposed term
limits
uh but without a doubt it was the best
job in the world
so so what brought you to cable news i
mean as if you hadn't had enough fights
in the courtroom and then running for
prosec you know all of this all d.a and
all that it's like
what i mean there's no fight like a
cable news fight
well i i must tell you that that for
whatever reason i got involved in
television
and it was the o.j simpson case i
believe it was 1994
uh and that bronco chase and i remember
i had just become the d.a
and i had you know all 150 assistant
da's at my home
and one of the guys came out i think it
was one of the investigators who said
hey boss you're not going to believe it
o.j simpson's in a bronco they're
chasing him i said what are they chasing
him for is he speeding
nobody knew but that was really the
advent
of you know my introduction into the
importance of the media
in identifying and trying to you know
change
certain issues in our society so for
battered women
you know i started the first unit in the
nation under the department of justice
uh and people kept thinking better than
women
sex is better for them after after
they're beaten or they deserved it
or you know she's a pain in the ass and
you know as a woman assistant d.a i had
to deal with 43
male police chiefs in my jurisdiction
and deal with that kind of there was a
discrimination and the thinking was
marriage is forever be a better wife if
he's beating you'll be a better wife go
pray
and so we were part part of a change
it made a tremendous difference uh but i
saw the importance of the media
and as a prosecutor i used the media to
help me identify
issues and get more victims to come
forward
so just hearing your history a little
bit and some of this stuff i i actually
didn't know does it drive you crazy when
people say oh conservatives or
anti-women
or conservatives or anti-gay or
conservatives or racists
or the rest of it we've talked a little
bit about that on your show but but when
you hear some of the things that you've
been involved doing
it it's kind of crazy that that people
get these labels on them
and you know that the movie that they
made about
uh roger ailes and the women at fox who
had all these issues and and for any
victim
anyone is truly a victim remember as a
prosecutor i had to decide
is it real is it credible is it
believable
does it make sense uh you know my my
heart goes out to them and my passion
went out to them along with my
my energy um but in the movie that they
made and i never saw it
they portrayed me as someone who was as
i understand it apologetic
for you know the the the the offenders
and yeah it made me crazy dave it
made me nuts i said to myself for all
those
hashtag me too women where the
hell were you in the late 70s and the
early 80s when i was fighting for
children to testify
where the hell were you when i was
trying to make it illegal to put women
on a lie detector test who claimed that
they were raped
where were you when i was fighting to
make sure that women couldn't be judged
because they wore a short skirt which
then allows the defense attorney to say
you were asking for it you wear a rolex
in your burglarized date
or or uh someone robs you
they're not going to say hey you wore
that rolex because you wanted to be
robbed
but a woman wears a short skirt she wore
that skirt because she wanted to be
raped
you know i wanna it makes me crazy
because i've spent my life fighting for
the silent victims of crime for
women uh for the elderly for children
people have no idea what happens to
children in our system today
you know i started getting reports of
suspected child abuse
in the late 70s and they said to me
you're not entitled to those
i said yes i am and there's a certain
benefit to naivete i just
in my my moral course said moani of
course you are
and they said no these are privileged
they stay with social services
so i had an all-out war and i was going
to sue the department of social
services i went to the d.a and he says
oh let little janine let let her go
do her social things uh and it turned
out i said to them look
if a social worker goes and finds that a
child is
maybe being abused but returns the child
to the parents
that record is then expunged and maybe
if they're called again
and they don't find anything that record
is expunged
but the third time the kid is dead okay
i
want the first record and the second
record and don't you dare tell me
that i can't get a history of abuse in a
criminal case when i got the homicide of
that child
and i did child abuse homicides that was
one of my expertise
whether it's chicken baby syndrome
immersion in scalding water
uh being beaten to death i mean i could
tell you stories that make your hair
stand and i don't talk about it often
dave and i don't know you just kind of
hit a thing in my head
very rarely do people even know what i
did other than oh she was a d.a whatever
that means
no i have a passion uh and i have
an empathy for the victim the victim was
everything to me why do we name the
system
dave think about this the criminal
justice system
it should be the victim justice system
the victim
never wanted to be a part of this but
all of a sudden like a
thunderbolt their lives are changed and
the ripple effect to their family and
the community
it's just it's enormous and you know
what we're seeing today is just an
example of all that
craziness so when you hear people
talk about systemic racism that is in
our criminal justice system
um well i guess first do you think that
exists
and and if it does exist um can you give
me
an example of it or a time that you came
up against it
um i absolutely do not believe there's
systemic racism
i think that the laws are in place to
protect
everyone and and i've watched those laws
evolve over the years but in terms of
what i've done let me be real clear
about this
are there bad cops yes absolutely
have i prosecuted bad cops yes
absolutely
did i like it i didn't really like it or
dislike
it it was the only way to handle it i
prosecuted an off-duty new york city
police officer
for shooting an african-american over a
parking space in westchester
dave to this day
that guy who was the cop i convicted him
he was convicted my office convicted him
was convicted
and he went to prison for 25 years to
this day
these guys are after me for doing that
now
i had no idea but al sharpton who i knew
because i ran for office uh you know so
many times
al sharpton wanted to make a visit he
called my secretary at the time they
were secretaries and
she said boss uh al sharpton wants to
visit you with a few reverends i said
yeah why not you know that's fine
so they came in one morning after the
verdict about three or four days
and they brought in pastries and we made
coffee for them and you know i sat and i
kind of waited for a second and they
said we want to thank you
and i said what and they said
never in the history of new york has a
white cop been convicted
of killing a black man and
i didn't realize that it was historic am
i proud of it no
i'm not proud of it i'm not ashamed of
it it was a horrible thing that happened
but it was a right thing to do but to
this day when the nypd gave me an award
two years ago that guy's friends the
white cops friends from new york city
are still after me i have a radio show
wabc
they call me up and say you're this and
that you know and then i just go like
that they get rid of the call
but i um i've come across a lot of uh
a lot of cases that were ugly but if
your moral core
is strong if you know who you are
if you're not a weakling then it's easy
you do what you have to do so actually
i wasn't going to ask you this but i
think it's sort of the the perfect segue
before we get to the book so
speaking of speaking of moral core and
doing what you think is right and all
that
you're a new yorker as you know i'm born
and bred new yorker until i moved out to
cali
eight years ago so i've only lived in
new york and california
um what what is it do you think about
new york like you strike me as such a
new yorker like no
in the best sense of what new york is
you know people think new york
if you're from new york cal you're crazy
but but i mean new york in
just sort of the ethnic makeup of new
york and the no bs and and call it as it
is and all that can you just tell me a
little bit about just like your your
family makeup and where some of that
came from
sure i'd be happy to um i'm of lebanese
descent
i don't know if you even knew that
everyone assumes because my i married an
italian and my name is italian
yeah i thought you were purebred off the
boat from sicily
no no i'm lebanese christian both my mom
and dad
um my dad fought in world war ii he was
not first generation my grandfather
fought in world war
ii but i'm 100 uh lebanese uh
christian and um we kept the subculture
alive i cooked the food i cooked hamus
tambouli and baba ghanoush and other
grape leaves i do all that stuff
uh but i'm gonna surprise you i grew up
in a small town in upstate
new york and i worked in a dairy uh as
a young kid and uh so this
you know people say to me are you from
the bronx are you from greece
actually i'm from elmira and they're
like where is that
um and uh in fact dave for the longest
time
i had pot belly pigs in my yard here in
westchester
uh you know the pigs yeah those are
and one lived uh i think it was 16 years
i mean i just liked farm animals
and uh you know it was it's upstate new
york was more like
middle america you know and uh i learned
how to shoot a gun
um church was important education was
important i'm the first one in my family
to go to college
uh and uh you know it was a very simple
very simple life nothing complicated
about it
and and my mom passed uh last year in
the room right above us here i had her
in hospice and
and you know she was everything she gave
me
you know the moral compass to both
empathize
uh and she gave me that that that heart
for victims you know they they just
weren't people that you prosecuted for
they were your family and um
and yet the tough side of me came from
being a prosecutor
you know i was the first woman that went
out on a homicide review
and you know i remember the first time i
went out on a homicide
call um i went out you know like the
first thing i said you know laugh
i said like the call comes in of course
at three in the morning homicides only
happen at three in the morning
so after they have an argument with my
then husband
that uh the he was going to get his wife
and they kept saying no we want the
assistant d.a
because i was the first and um
so i yeah i say to my husband after they
tell me the location
i say what do you wear to a homicide
oh god what a dumb thing to say he said
it doesn't matter what you wear janine
just take the peen along with you
so when i got there they didn't want to
let me on the scene and i said no no i'm
really an assistant d.a
i was like 25 years old so um
yeah it's been an interesting career and
uh i'm very very lucky i had a simple
life
to deal with this complicated world i'm
pretty sure the title of your next book
is what are you wearing to a homicide i
think i think we've got
i think we got that right there oh and
by the way for the record i do know
elmira because i went to suny binghamton
so i know a little bit i know a little
bit about the southern tier
yeah oh my gosh w-e-n-y
yeah do you remember w-e-n-y of course i
do and
did you see not well
i could fall down a mountain pretty
decently yeah
oh my gosh yeah my grandfather lived in
binghamton anyway
so yeah all right so let's let's shift a
little bit here
um i know that this interview right now
is
obviously your biggest interview of the
week but a few days ago
you did sit down with this other guy i'm
sure some of my audience has heard about
him before
uh this this donald trump fella
i'm sure some people have heard of him
um can you just tell me a little bit
sort of like what is the preparation as
an interviewer to do that i know you
have a relationship and he you know he
calls in and all that kind of stuff
um but like just what's it like sitting
down with the guy and and trying to
just make sense of the world with him
right now
you know as you as you said i've i've
known
donald trump um for about 35 years um
my then husband al who answered the
phone
and fought with this this sergeant he
kept saying
i'm not the assistant d.a janine is uh
represented donald for years so we spent
time
most weekends going to florida with
donald
um when my kids were little and his kids
were little
and um so i know the man i know donald
trump the man i i
i have a sense of you know who he is and
um i i know a side of him not the
caricature that they make him out to be
i know that he's brilliant but to answer
your question directly how do you sit
down and prepare for it
um i try to first thing you do
is you figure out topics what do you
want to talk to them about biggest
issues right now
are the pandemic uh the rioting
and the looting of the election the
debate
joe biden is he capable and the things
that no one was talking about that i
thought was so important
were the nobel peace prize i mean the
abraham awards just signed
i mean talk about israel the united arab
emirates
israel and bahrain i mean this is big
stuff
and you know apparently the saudis are
about to follow
uh so i talked to him about that and um
i write my questions out and you know
i've never talked to anyone else at fox
on how they do it it's almost like
you're trying a case
you know but it's your direct case it's
not really a cross-examination
uh but you know that you're gonna have
to push a little bit
so what there are two questions where i
pushed
the one question was um look
said something like mr president i know
that you have to be invited into certain
areas
in order to bring in the national guard
as you did in milwaukee and as you did
in kenosha
but there are some places they will just
not have you in
and they'd rather see rioting and
looting uh
the word is that on election night
assuming that there's a winner
uh and if you win if you are the winner
uh and there are the promised riots
looting
and anarchy what will you do he said
we'll put it down very quickly what will
you do
we're gonna put it down very quickly
what will you do
he said insurrection he's going to use
the insurrection act
and i you know i knew that at some point
he had to admit that he was going to use
it but
i said why not now and he said not it's
not ready yet this isn't the time
yet so i think what he is preparing for
is something really big on election
night where were you
on election night do you remember 2016
where are we
yeah i was on air uh on the daily wire
with ben shapiro and
and the crew over there and the the one
my one takeaway of the night i don't
know if you know uh andrew clavin who's
one of the hosts on the daily wire he
said something that i thought was really
brilliant that night
he said only in america could the thing
that everyone said couldn't happen
could happen and i thought well all
right whether you whether you love trump
or hate trump the fact
that something like that can happen that
all the pundits could get it wrong
all the pollsters could get it wrong all
the elites could get it wrong
that's actually pretty beautiful that
goes to the strength of our democracy
actually
you know and it really does go to the
strength of our democracy that it's not
so predictable it's not so set in stone
it's not as though people are
orchestrating it
um i remember coming out uh of the
hilton
uh on election morning it was like 3 30
or 4 in the morning
and i was just so excited i mean i think
buzzfeed one of them had a picture of me
standing on a chair with a trump hat on
and i had the loudest dress i could wear
i was like orange flowers or something
and so i'm like dancing out of the hotel
and all of a sudden they somebody starts
cursing at me
and you know and i look down and i look
up the guy's like
6'4 and he's cursing me out and you know
not not a shy new yorker i went right
back at him
uh although he was taller than me uh
although he was in a tutu
but he was really tall so uh the cop
said to me
judge come over here i said no make him
go over there
you know i'm really stupid sometimes
you're a new yorker whatever the reason
is i was stupid
and so then they start another guy
started coming out cursing me she's a
trump person
so the reason i bring it up is
i guarantee you that 2020 if the
president is announced as the winner
that night
it's going to be wild and um
i truly believe he will win i think that
even people dave
in those towns where there's anarchy
like portland and seattle and i know
those are liberal states
and uh like oregon and all that but
there are people now who are afraid
they're afraid they survived kind of the
pandemic
and they have one shot to get back their
business which is the security for their
family
which is their their their ego their
sense of self their sense of self worth
our jobs are who we
are and bang the protesters come in and
destroy it
i don't think they want the left
controlling that
and getting away with impunity this is
impunity
but it's not one thing dave it's not
like all of a sudden it was a perfect
storm
that george george um uh george floyd
died
and you know everybody said all right
let's revolt no you don't find bricks in
the middle of
a pandemic right nobody's building
anything in manhattan
and all of a sudden all over the country
there's no bail
statutes so everyone is being arrested
is being let out
and even the ones who are being arrested
they've now got
prosecutors who have been elected with
the support of the democrat socialists
of america who are saying
we're not prosecuting them we're not
putting people in jail
we're letting people out of jail and so
now this whole layer that we haven't
even noticed
is on fire and it is set
for a huge turnaround and this is the
last chance we have in this country to
secure
law order so that all right so that
brings us to the book because
i i read a bunch of it this morning and
and the first the opening of the book in
essence
you say this is a battle of good and
evil
and you know i've sort of come around to
that like i don't
like thinking that my ideological
enemies are evil and i think a lot of
them have good intentions
but i think in effect at this point this
thing that we're fighting that you're
talking about this
this marxist revolution and antifa and
blm and this whole thing
it has become evil even if some of them
do have good intentions
do you really believe that this is this
is sort of the last stand that the you
know we always say this is the most
important election ever
but do you really feel like this is it
like this is the the final stand
you know you're right we always say it
people always say this is the most
important election in your lifetime
i really mean it this time i mean i
would take an oath
on this you know i would go to church on
this um
because there's so much at stake and
we're right at the precipice where
it'll all fall um i spent
32 years in law enforcement in the
courts in the criminal justice system
uh i know that that that is my
wheelhouse
and what is happening now uh with the
defunding of police
with the stand down police orders with
the no bail
with prosecutors who are refusing to
prosecute
what we've got now is total anarchy
and when the left talks about open
borders
locking you down defunding the police
and when kamala harris says the
constitution
doesn't stop her from taking away our
guns
we got real problems we've got real
problems and you know what i think i
think
not just the people who live in the
cities that have been destroyed
milwaukee kenosha which is small town
america
milwaukee and chicago and and and
seattle and portland and and
detroit and uh not detroit so much
they're in good shape
but washington and so many cities new
york city
i mean the democrats know what they need
and they need law enforcement they need
a criminal justice people in the inner
city
know that the vast majority of victims
of of of a crime
are a black on black crime okay
they know they need protection and so
the black reverends the hispanic pastors
and all that other sub-priests
they want law enforcement in the
community but the criminals are now
emboldened i'm not telling you anything
you don't already know and that you talk
about dave
but this is the last chance people are
walking around with guns in their in
their
in their waistbands they're not worried
about anything because
just as i unearth there was a memo the
d.a in manhattan sci-vans
handed out right after one of the huge
protests which involved looting and
burning and anarchists and and
all kinds of uh uh a theft
the d.a comes out in this internal memo
to his staff and he says we're going to
give the protesters their protesters
mind you they're protesters yeah i'm
approaching cds
or dismissals but if any of those
protesters have
any information about police misbehaving
in their arrest or mishandling them we
will take those cases and prosecute them
so let the protesters go and turn turn
it the tables
on the cops really two cops in compton
you know i mean i'm sick i'm sick
people laughing people laughing a woman
shot through the jaw
trying to say what her number is this is
not america
how worried are you that this the state
of the state
of the system because of everything that
you just described there
that in a certain way it almost has to
get worse before it can get better that
you can't get a reset
when you have so many sort of cowardly
da's
now cowardly it's i don't blame the a
lot of the police chiefs or the average
policeman who's retiring early i don't
blame him it's like if you're not going
to be backed up by your politicians i
don't blame them
but do you think it has to get worse
because enough of them will have to
disappear
and maybe you have to then vote in
completely new
politicians most likely republicans
without
complete chaos happening that it can't
reset otherwise
well i think two things i think number
one
it has to get worse and it will get
worse
okay there's no question the president
is not going to use insurrection
unless it does get worse he said the
time is is not now
um and i also think that these
i'm so sorry
you got your own insurrection over there
yeah i'm so sorry
uh but i also think that um
these these politicians these
prosecutors are
in i mean they're not going to be voted
out for a few years
but the money that's coming in to
support antifa
outside money and the money that's
coming in to fund these people flying
from one city to another city where
they're bailed out in one city to then
go to another city
i mean there's big money behind the
destruction of this country
all right so let's let's just hit a
couple other things that you go into in
the book so since we've talked about
new york and so much of your your
history is in new york
uh you're not a fan of bill de blasio
the uh the mayor of new york city i
believe you call him bozo
de blasio um are you shocked how quickly
the city has devolved under him even
even though i know you don't agree with
any of his policies but like
just the rapid rate that so much of the
city has just turned into chaos
look the man is either stupid
incompetent
or both all right that's what i think of
bozo
the guy is a bozo i mean first of all
the fact that he would
move to defund the police the fact that
he started half of this police
uh hatred in new york he's been very
very much pushing that agenda
he doesn't support the police and i
talked to a lot of the upper echelon in
the police department the
top ranks there i mean they that he
they cannot deal with him and he can't
deal with them he's
never been a fan of law enforcement but
by not deploying police when there was
looting going on on fifth avenue in
manhattan
now i'm not saying because that you know
they're wealthier there they deserve
protection i'm not saying that at all
because if you got a bodega and that's
all you got then that's your castle and
you deserve protection
because you're paying taxes too but
things that are so obvious
so apparent all you have to do is deploy
the the the police
he didn't do it i mean i was told he
told them
you're going to stand down or not
deploying them the same with macy's in
harold square
they're trying to start a fire in macy's
why is he so happy with that
and the dumbest thing the man ever said
when he said
oh no these are peaceful protesters
you're blind too
um where he says we're going to allow
them to protest
because this is a historic moment in
history
are you kidding it's a historic moment
in history
but don't you dare go to church don't
don't you jews dare have a funeral
don't you dare do any go back to work
don't you dare and then
then cuomo wants to deploy what was a 4
000 please to monitor the uh
restaurants to make sure people are
wearing masks when they go in the
restaurants
when you don't have police a woman was
raped on a platform
you know in the middle of the day there
are people walking around in manhattan
men without their pants on
and they're drinking alcohol from a
paper bag in a pla a flask in a paper
bag
i mean he the man doesn't have a clue
what do you think what do you think he
thinks i mean
he obviously i don't say he obviously
doesn't want to destroy the city i don't
know what the guy wants like what do you
think
he thinks is supposed to happen because
of his policies
you know i remember he said something
that just floored me
uh when they said he said they said mr
mayor this is right in the beginning
crime is going up and his answer was
something like well we'll hit the
streets and we'll talk about it
yeah crime is going to go down when you
talk about it you're about as scary as
big bird
you know i mean this guy is from another
he's from another time i don't know
your question really is is he
intentionally doing it
you know uh does he hate new york i
think look
this guy is uh wilhelm comrade de blasio
i mean the guy even changed his name
he's a phony
you know he changed his name from
wilhelm the third or whatever
and you know i believe he he believes in
in communism i really do he doesn't
believe in
law and order that's not his agenda i
mean his wife sherlane
says that new york would be nirvana
without the police
she i'm gonna stop right there yeah
speaking as a judge since you mentioned
andrew cuomo cuomo
said that uh eating wings is not a meal
that doesn't count as a meal
is there any legal uh precedent behind
that
my god when did he say that that's what
he said because
he said it a couple of weeks ago because
you know what happened was some of the
bars started opening up and the way they
got around it was they started serving
because he said you have to have a meal
so they started serving wings and then
the governor decided that wings are not
a meal what does that tell you dave it
tells you that they want to lock
us down that whatever excuse
they can use to prevent us from going
out is the excuse they're going to use
fear is a very big factor in control
and you know i'm seeing people now that
i haven't seen in months dave
and they're like oh yeah you know
they're just different they're afraid
they're afraid of everything
you know now that the winter's coming
people are going to start you know
go staying inside and they operate on
that
and you know joe biden i this one really
knocked me out
joe biden and uh and his wife jill
i think it was memorial day the first
you know weekend of the summer pretty
much
and they've been in the basement in the
bunker forever
right and the two of them are going to
put a uh
some flowers on a uh on one of the uh
burial plots they're walking together
the two of them
in black masks from here to here just
the two of them
no one's with them why you've been
together
bunkered up for months and now at the
end of may you're coming out with black
mass just the two of you there's no one
in sight
what does that tell you it's a whole
mindset
they have to be careful and the mask is
black
so what would you be doing if you were
mayor of new york city or you were
governor of new york at this point
uh with lockdowns and everything else
what would it what do you think would be
a sensible way about going about it
a sensible thing to do would be to meet
with the business people to bring the
businessmen
and bring law enforcement and and to
have a
high level meeting on what they need and
what we're going to do
and how we can do it together uh and i
think right now that with the defunding
of police assuming that's already been
done
that we've got to convince the police
that maybe they're going to have to work
with some of these private
security guards and at least share
information on what's going on because
intelligence is one of the most
important things you can have in law
enforcement
and there's got to be an open line of
communication
people have to be able to go to work
look you don't think we've had enough of
this
you don't think people know wear a mask
wash your hands
don't touch things wear gloves i mean
everybody knows what they have to do
this is america we this is the land of
the free and the home of the brave
let us out don't give me this hog wash
how you have to lock me down you're not
locking me down anymore
you can't tell me what to do you can't
take my gun
you can't tell me what to say you can't
lock me in my home i've had enough of
all of you
judge that is absolutely our clip for
this episode that was
that was the promo right there you just
made it you just made it very easy for
my guys
um so you mentioned you mentioned biden
there in chapter three is about bunker
biden
um joking aside for a second even
politics aside
what what do you think is going on with
him cognitively
or health-wise because it seems to me
i've been saying this for a while that
the scandal is not
that something is is wrong with him that
seems obvious to everyone
the scandal is that there's no scandal
the scandal is that the media won't talk
about it when we can all see it
do you think that's a fair estimation i
mean what do you think is really
happening there
well i think you're absolutely on point
there i think the amazing part of it is
that you know when this speaks to the
whole issue of the
of the media and their complicity with
the left
uh there you know i asked the president
about this
and uh you know he said to me and he the
president's a wise man he said you know
he said it was almost even between joe
biden and bernie sanders in that debate
and i thought so too when i saw it joe
biden was on his game
and i said why what do you think
accounts for the fact that
one day he can't finish a sentence and i
mean it's you you just cringe
for him and then you know the next day
he'll do something
with biden or and and obviously they're
afraid to let him out
how is this guy gonna run the country
when he's he does one appearance
no questions gets back in his car and
goes home for three days and rests
he's in a presidential campaign i mean
how's he gonna run the country
how's he gonna who's gonna match what's
with putin or kim jong-un
or or uh uh what's his name
he can't do it he can't do it so what's
going on with him um you know people say
that there are certain medications that
you know can make him more lucid
but to me the telltale was last night
when pamela harris said
the harris administration along with joe
biden
i said to myself janine
what is going on in the back rooms
what are they planning why is it that
she's referring to herself as the
harris administration with joe biden
is he the entree you know just to get in
because i can't believe the man is
capable of running this country
he doesn't i don't know if you i don't
know if you saw this but like
literally about 15 minutes before we
started this he flubbed it today too
and he called it the harris biden
administration
literally it happened like 15 minutes
before we went live or before we started
recording
i rest my case where is ipsa the thing
speaks for itself
razip's a locator little latin so let's
back up for a second because because you
know trump and a lot of my audience
you know a bit about my political
evolution and that i was i was a bernie
supporter and a progressive and a lefty
and all those things and i
you're good you're a pro you're a pro i
should be judged accordingly for all of
those things
um but i know that there's a lot of my
audience that
i would say they don't consider
themselves conservative per se or even
on the right but they consider
themselves
what i would say is sort of the
disaffected liberal
and i think that is a huge huge amount
of people in america right now the
liberals that just can't believe how
bananas the left has gone
but i think the other piece of that is
they just find
something about trump off-putting
whether it's the way he speaks or the
tweeting or whatever something like that
so since you know him and you talked
about it a little bit already can you
just
if you wanted people to be more okay
that that he does love this country that
he's a decent guy
and it took me a long time to get there
by the way i think i mentioned this on
your show it wasn't until i actually met
him and i had about 10 minutes to talk
to him
that i felt more okay when he when he
literally
turned to my husband and i and he goes
you guys are gay
he goes that's great your only problem
is you're too handsome and i thought
this is the guy who
says everyone's at home you know they
they say he think that he's a homophobe
um but since you know him a little bit
more yeah can you just dive into that
you know um donald trump is not the
caricature that they make him out to be
and you know i
i just i there are certain little
vignettes that i remember
you know when when my kids would be we'd
go we'd fly down to florida we had a
house and of course he had mar-a-lago
um and and he would say very quietly to
his kids
don't talk to her like that you don't
talk to your sister like that you don't
talk to him like that never raise his
voice
you know he was always serious and then
when he got a little more upset it would
be
no no emotion you just lost your
allowance
keep it up keep it up he was always
attentive to their behavior
and how they acted toward each other and
and i i'll never forget it was
it was sort of the beginning of of uh
school or
uh no the second semester i guess and he
said
when we land we're going to kmart to get
our school supplies you said to the kids
and i'm like
donald trump goes to kmart wow
but when we would walk down the street
in manhattan we went out with him a lot
um he was always kind to me he would say
to people you know this janine piro
she's a d.a
you know from westchester and i was
always on television for something
and um and he was always
more um you know it was beholding and
trying to get people to
to recognize you instead of him whenever
he saw a cop
whenever he saw a construction worker a
hard hat and they were
all enamored with him they were like oh
hi and
they didn't have phone cameras maybe
back then but they
say can i shake your hand he would
absolutely do it
whenever we'd go into a restaurant and
have dinner or something
he'd march right into that kitchen and
take care of everybody in the kitchen
he is a good generous man and his
kids are a testament to the success
uh that he instilled in them every one
of them i mean those kids are smart
they're successful
they're brilliant they really are and as
a human being
you know you go through tough periods in
your life or your career
he was always there for me or you know
for my then husband he was
always there always generous in spirit
loved his brother robert i was at the
white house for the uh
uh for the wake uh was very
very sad about that um very family
oriented dave
they were always together he was with
his sisters and his brother
um and never drank and i remember when i
interviewed him in 2016 right before
um he ran uh he was there was talk of
him running and
i said you want to tell people you don't
drink he said no i don't drink never had
a drink
and people were floored by that but i've
seen him in parties
all hours of the day and night go to
mar-a-lago everybody be
you know half in the bag not donald
trump
he i love the guy he's he's a wonderful
wonderful man
and he loves this country and you know
what i don't know anyone dave who could
take the assaults that he's taken
on a daily basis and survive them the
guy looks better than ever
usually after four years you're you're
exhausted
he's raring to go no i know he's he's
more bronze than usual now it's it's
very it must be because of peace in the
middle east that it made in bronze or
something but but speaking of
the human side of things i've had a
bunch of the fox hosts
on and you know you guys all just get
endlessly trashed in the media
and you get the media matters boycotts
and they go for your sponsors and all of
that stuff
and i don't know how comfortable you
comfortably you'll be talking about this
but you did
mention to me once how it can take a
toll
you know when you're when you're in your
town and oh there's judging she's on
fox and just dealing with some some of
that kind of hate and yet you always
have a smile on your face i mean
what what's that like just just being
you you live in new york
you you're a public person and you got
to deal with some
some pretty hateful stuff yeah i do i do
but you see
the difference for me is um i ran for
office five times
i am hardened with steel uh and uh i'm
used to it i mean i
used to boycott me for this or that or
i'd prosecute a case they didn't like it
or uh you know you know i really don't
care
if if you care enough that
uh you're thinking about changing your
mind then
care and change your mind but if you're
if you believe that what you're doing is
right
i don't give it a second thought but
what i am
amazed uh at or with is the fact that
people on the left dropped me you know
when trump got elected
my friends dropped me and i was like but
i would never drop you
you know i just wouldn't it all started
you know we all got dropped and i i
found that hurt
that hurt i know the feeling it hurt
and you know when you try you know to to
not
maybe sound as crazy and then you just
say you know what
i am who i am it's a short visit here
dave
all of us are here for a short time and
if you
if you can't be who you are and if you
don't know who you are
then you better you know reintroduce
yourself to yourself
and uh get moving so i have i have no
regrets
and i also uh don't worry about those
people
uh and i also am a gun owner i have six
guns
you know i am i am a new gun owner so uh
we we share some things in common so you
end the book
uh fittingly with a closing statement so
i feel that we should end this uh
interview with a closing statement i
mean if
if someone picks up your book and we're
six weeks now roughly but when the book
comes out about five weeks before
the election what is it that you want
them to take
more than anything else from the book
i want people to recognize that uh
it is it's not just about the lies i
mean i identify the lies and i go
through the lies
but the most important thing for them to
understand is that there's a quote from
abraham lincoln uh
from his speech at lyceum where he talks
about
the destruction of this country will not
come from a foreign source
it will come from within and that's what
we're facing right now
we're facing an absolute um
destruction of america as we know it
from forces within america
and we can't let that happen we can't we
can't forget
who we are how free we are
and we can't not protect americans and
our families and our businesses
you know we were happy we really were i
mean some people are just
miserable but um this is really the land
of the free and the home of the brave
and we need to continue to be that
i don't need anyone to tell me that
america was never so great or america
sucks you know if you don't like america
well then don't live here you know
but uh we can always make changes
evolution is part of who we are
but uh i love this country and donald
trump does too
and i know that judge i was originally
going to end this interview by inviting
myself to your house so that i could
have like spaghetti and meatballs or
your famous lasagna but now that i know
you're lebanese
it's going to be a tabouli and some baba
ghanoush and what's your what's your
specialty
uh i make something called shakameshi
which is eggplant with meat
and uh um you know some little
nuts it's delicious and whatever you
like i can cook all of it i love it
shish kebab what do you like what's your
pleasure
you're from you're from california you
like you like
like i know what you would like i would
make you like salmon
and chicken on a shish kebab with
peppers and onions and tomatoes all that
stuff that'd be good you see how i just
invited myself over and you laid out the
menu for me pretty pretty good huh
i'd love to cook there's there's a
mother in me you know i
i oh i beg my kids i say come home guys
mom's cooking they're like yay
she's cooking thank you judge
judge i appreciate your friendship and i
hope people got to see you
in a little bit of a new way here the
book is don't lie to me we're going to
link to it in the youtube description
and and hopefully we will do this in
person
one of these days yeah so thank you dave
and good luck to you and it's it was a
pleasure
thank you if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
watch our full episode playlist all
right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell